all right I am here with Tim Robbins
actor producer writer you don't you know
what you do but you are also the founder
of the actors getting which to talk to
bill on the show about this amazing
project that you do with the prisons and
there's so much that goes into it and
everything that you just said was so
interesting but we didn't really talk
about the fact that all the stuff costs
money for props and fur
costumes and makeup people's time right
well salaries - yeah yes and we have
never gotten a dollar from state funding
so we it's been a privately funded
project and so we rely on the public -
to fund us and right now we're actually
in the middle of a crowd rise campaign
very nice and we're raising money for
the prison project which you can do
through Crowdrise
and look for the RT gang or you can go
to our website at the actors game.com
and then it's a link to that campaign
and you were telling bill the story
started talking about this story about
the magnanimous ass it's pretty amazing
what happened we had been training this
group of inmates in a certain part of
the prison we had done about three or
four sessions with them and then we told
them we're going to move into a
different part of the prison more
high-security and and we said you know
you're on your own
and as and eight months later we found
out that they had been gone to the
prison and asked for a room one day a
week and this a couple of the people
that we had trained took it upon
themselves to train 40 new inmates in
this kind of work and this training and
this ability to you know reform
themselves and deal with their emotions
in a more productive way than the way
that landed them in praise
and we went back and when they invited
us they had written a play called the
magnanimous ass and they had performed
it they had they performed it but they
had made costumes they have made
commedia dell'arte masks out of paper
and glue and the shoe leather from their
prison-issue boots and they had made
this incredible thing there was live
music there was um and it was the story
was amazing too because it was about
this this magnanimous task that and
Island where all these guys were stuck
and they all tried to get off of the
island for individual reasons and
eventually the lesson they learned from
the magnanimous ass is that once they
start collectively working towards
something or looking after each other
then they can start to think about
getting off the island so with a little
bit of prison resourcefulness thrown in
there yes and a lot of metaphor right
yeah that sounds like a contagious thing
like you give these guys the tools to do
it they you know to kind of improve
themselves and then they can spread it
around without you even being there in
it there was a really inspiring thing
for us as doing the program it's for all
the people that are teachers that go in
it and we we've seen the effectiveness
of it we we have guys tell us that they
can talk to their families for the first
time their children are made but that
they can express emotions they've never
expressed before they can legitimize
their own existence imprisoned by their
own acknowledgement of their own
humanity through this program and they
can accept responsibility more and work
towards goals together and solve
problems together and it's a very very
productive inspiring program and
I know it works I've seen it I had one
guy tell me that he was there's this one
prison drug that was very mean to them
and would put them in or into their
dorms early and take them out late and
all this aggressive behavior and abuse
use of language and and after you see
since after I took the course he said I
started looking at that guy in a
different way and whereas before I hated
him now I was just I felt like what is
going on in this guy's life that he has
to act out this way so that's actual
empathy for a person that's oppressing
me which is a highly advanced emotion
and that these guys are able to get
there by this work it's really really a
good news for all of us when these kinds
of guys get out of prison the chicken
and they will and there and they will
and they will deal with adversity when
they come out they would be up a job
that they thought they were gonna have
that they don't get and there will be an
emotional response from a partner or a
loved one that they didn't expect and
this kind of training allowed it gives
them the tools to to weather this storm
and to stop this cycle of reoffending
that is an amazing program thank you so
much for putting your time into that
pleasure go check out the actors gang
website and contribute to their
Crowdrise initiative there and go ahead
and see thanks for sharing and theaters
because it's gonna be great all right
thanks thanks a lot
right